die ungeheure sicherheit pablo picasso
das genie
die legendären aufnahmen aus wisse
picasso lassen immer wieder staunen
doch wer verbirgt sich hinter diesem
blick ein halbes jahrhundert zuvor schon
der jüngling ein genie antworten geben
kann die frau der diese zeichnungen
gewidmet sind
angela rosengart tochter eines
kunsthändlers der picasso als
aufstrebenden maler kennen werte wir
treffen sie im studierzimmer der
sammlung rosengart ein museum in luzern
dass sie mit ihrem vater aufgebaut hat
um werke aus dem familienbesitz
zugänglich zu machen
darunter über 30 gemälde picassos die 86
jährige nimmt uns mit auf eine zeitreise
[Musik]
eigentlich ganz fremd glaube was da
alles charmante etwas melancholische
junge mann wurde ich weiß nicht dass der
sport der picasso ist
danach folgt die australier
sportlichkeit den wänden picasso die
derner jahren kennt im raum sie ist mit
viele menschen
ähnlich schätzt schütteln in der 4
ja da fängt es bereits und denn
natürlich hier das muss unser vierter
ist bereits gegossen absolute und
kennecott kamen die fünfziger sechziger
jahre
fortan trifft sie ihn immer wieder um
zusammen mit ihrem vater
rechts im bild werke zu kaufen bis zu
picassos tod fotografien und gleich
mehrere porträts der jungen frau zeugen
vom engen kontakt das ist unglaublich
für mich sie hätten wir es kühlt gefühlt
vor ihm erhält eine markt und metzger
der blick durch ein tor und mädchen gibt
irgendwie blut gefüllt aber durchschaut
es ist wirklich im blick sie wo ein auf
presse hätte
picasso der frauen verschlinge findet
gefallen an der mittzwanzigerin
porträtiert sie eine liaison entsteht
aber nicht zu groß der altersunterschied
von 50 jahren zumindest für angela
rosengart
fasziniert war sie jedoch von seiner
natürlichkeit
nie habe er sie spüren lassen ein star
zu sein
[Musik]
da ist er noch kein star
sondern ein suchender bettelarm zum
ersten mal in paris
davon erfahren wir in rom wo wir seine
nichte treffen
sie empfängt in einem hotel in dem auch
der meister schon mal residierte diana
widmaier picasso immobilien des rituals
fischervereins musste er gar eine
leinwand verbrennen um sich zu wärmen
dieser ganze kontext ist essenziell um
zu verstehen was er alles ausdrücken
will nicht nur melancholie und
traurigkeit die armut der menschen in
frankreich sondern auch seine eigene
situation die nicht immer einfach war
auffällig damals die zahlreichen
selbstporträts in zeiten in denen
fotografie und kino aufblühen will er
dass sich die öffentlichkeit auch von
ihm ein bild macht und setzt sich in
szene nennt sich ab 1901 stadt pablo
ruiz picasso nur noch picasso er findet
seine identität was es schwierig macht
meinen großvater ganz zu fassen ist die
komplexität seiner person
denn einerseits gab es diese kraft die
er hat er uns dahinter eine insel
sensibilität die ihn früh dazu brachte
sich mit der vergänglichen natur des
menschen auseinander zu setzen mit
seinem einfühlsamen figurativen frühwerk
das noch weit weg ist von den
abstraktionen späterer phasen gelingen
picasso bald erste verkaufserfolge
erfüllt bestätigung
[Musik]
er sagte selbst etwas was ich liebe wenn
ich soldat wäre würde ich ruthmann
werden wenn ich mich wäre würde ich
papst werden aber ich wollte maler
werden
also wurde ich picassos er lässt sich
von den verlockungen des modernen
künstlerlebens berauschen braucht so die
öffentlichkeit das geschenk des himmels
das ihn gegeben worden war bringt ihn
unfehlbar dazu eine mission zu erfüllen
ich denke dieses engagement ist wichtig
man kann zweifellos an eine gewisse
arroganz das junge picasso denken der in
paris eintrifft um die welt zu erobern
aber ich glaube seine entschlossenheit
ging viel tiefer getroffen
eine entschlossenheit die den jungen
mann zum jahrhundertkünstler werden
lässt
[Musik]
das ist picasso längst als er 50 jahre
später an schüler rosengart porträtiert
unverändert bleibt sein selbstbewusst
interessiertes wesen was mich immer
fasziniert hat ist gigantisch auf
menschen und die neugier monaco ich
glaub ich bis ins hohe alter junge hat
einfach alles besser war es um ihn um
basiert das volle leben
ich bin ganz wichtig sei und das hätten
sichere als junge schon bretonischen
juni kennt aber bis ins höhere alter
angela rosengart hat picasso große teile
ihres museums in luzern gewidmet die
gemälde stammen überwiegend aus dem
späteren werk da ihr vater den künstler
erst nach der blauen und rosa periode
begegnet ist
doch in allen räumen sind erinnerungen
greifbar den schmuck von damals etwa auf
dem porträt verewigt trägt sie noch
heute
erinnerungen an ein genie wie es im
jüngling bereits angelegt ist und im
film wisse picasso eindrücklich
dokumentiert wird
denn wie gesagt diese ungeheure
sicherheit lässt wahrlich immer wieder
staunen
[Musik]